[Musique]
la grande soirée électorale se poursuit
tout de suite en bourgogne franche comté
dispositif exceptionnel pour ce premier
tour des élections régionales et
départementales des résultats des
réactions des analyses au plus près de
chez vous oui et on va tout de suite
vous redonner les résultats l'estimation
de notre partenaire ipsos steria en
bourgogne franche comté avec marie-guite
dufay dont la liste arrive largement en
tête de ce second tour avec 42 et demi
pour cent des suffrages devant la liste
du républicain gilles platret 24,4 suivi
de julien odoul du rassemblement
national 23,7 denis thuriau la
république en marche 9,4 pour cent denis
thuriau qui est sur ce plateau avec nous
pour commenter les résultats
bonsoir à vous également sur notre
plateau des régionales jérôme durain
socialiste président du groupe
majoritaire sortant au conseil régional
vous êtes également sénateur avant de
discuter je vous propose de découvrir
une déclaration la première déclaration
de marie-guite dufay à son arrivée à la
préfecture 7 et il ya quelques minutes
marie-guite dufay vous allez voir très
content d'eux selon elle l'union de la
gauche a payé on écoute donc maintenant
la responsabilité qui est la mienne
donc je suis partagé entre ce sentiment
de très très grande responsabilité
et puis et puis la joie la joie la
satisfaction du travail accompli et je
remercie avec beaucoup beaucoup de
chaleur tous ceux qui nient qu'ils ont
fait confiance j'ai voulu et d'alliances
dès le début je les dis je les dis tout
au long de cette campagne je la voulais
dès le premier tour cette alliance elle
n'a pas été possible au premier tour je
l' ai donc fait au deuxième tour et l'a
payé vous avez bien un excédent record
de voir les partenaires
écoutez je suis pas encore à mesurer
exactement comment ils se sont je vois
simplement que la dynamique de premier
tour elle s'est prolongée grâce à
l'alliance que nous avons noué donc donc
je m'en félicite et je remercie vraiment
tout ce qu'ils m'ont fait confiance
voilà marie-guite dufay il ya quelques
instants tout juste à la préfecture on
sera tout à l'heure avec julien oudoul
du rassemblement national en duplex dans
quelques minutes
jérôme durain vous fait la même analyse
que marie-guite dufay c'est la victoire
de l'union de la gauche ce soir la
gauche plurielle version jospin 97
c'est le résultat de d'une candidature
d'un projet d'un choix stratégique la
candidature c'est celle de marie du fait
j'entends docteur l'hyper prime aux
sortants mais marine duffel s'en sort
mieux que d'autres présidents de région
sortants donc il ya qu'il ya une
adhésion à sa personnel sans soir aussi
moins bien que beaucoup d'autres enfin
regarder les résultats vous verrez que
par action carole delga à gauche comme
elle ils sont françois bonneau d'autres
sont moins bien placé donc marie-guite
dufay elle incarne quelque chose en tête
réaliser la victoire de marie guite
dufay ce n'est pas la victoire de la
gauche
c'est le 2 mai marie-guite dufay c'est
c'est une femme qui a convaincu les
électeurs qu'elle était sincèrement
investi pour la bourgogne franche comté
donc d'abord c'est d'une incarnation
ensuite c'est un projet parce qu'on a
fait du boulot
ce qui a été sanctionnée c'est aussi le
travail réalisé et c'est le projet qu'on
veut continuer et puis c'est une
dynamique politique alors nous a dit
attention il faut aller avec en marche
elle a choisi elle toujours d'aller à
gauche et rassembler la gauche et ça a
payé puisque ont fait plus que le total
gauche du premier tour
donc ça prouve que ya une vraie
dynamique de rassemblement autour de
cette candidature
le total gauche du premier tour c'était
un peu plus de 40% et là vous êtes
effectivement un peu plus de 42 %
denis thuriau est ce que vous regrettez
toujours que marie-guite dufay ne vous
ai pas tendu la main ce soir non je ne
regrette pas d'abord je façon
républicaine je la félicite un bien
aussi du rhum durenque ici présents
qu'ils hurlent et revoilà le fait un
beau score et bravo à elle et à ses
colistiers
il faut savoir reconnaître les choses
même s'il ya que 35 % de votants grosso
modo donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
humble les uns les autres et qu'on
comprenne comment on va pouvoir essayer
d'aller chercher notre électorat
position ça venir
c'est vraiment compliqué après voilà jeu
dont je leur ai pas je pense que c'était
important que nous nous maintenions donc
un prêté la volonté de que je sois le
tremplin du rassemblement la seule que
je combats et je pense qu'il a un poids
qu'on peut partager jérôme durain je
pense que d'ailleurs notre maintien à
éviter que leur assemblée nationale de
monde parce qu'il est peu probable poids
et je pense que beaucoup de mes
électeurs se seraient peut-être tout
simplement abstenus certains sont partis
chez maguy du fait donc ce qui explique
aussi que je fais un moins bon score
mais je m'y attendais à partir et un
vote utile en fait les murs d'une partie
de vous dire quelque part
honnêtement j'en fais ici tu vois je
suis content d'avoir fait barrage au
rassemblement national des choses qui ne
vous pose avec jérôme durand mais je
pense que ça c'est une valeur qu'on
partage absolue et contrairement à ce
que d'aucuns de prêter mon maintien à
éviter que des gens n'aillent pas voter
donc montre l'abstentionnisme est donc
quelques pas mathématiquement fasse
monter aussi rassemblement national donc
non quelque part en tout cas le combat
était le même à prendre porte
différemment 9 4% des suffrages quel
était votre objectif vous avez
l'objectif ça aurait était d'intéresser
les amis à 300 milles qui n'ont pas voté
et serait plus correctement renverser la
table et changer les choses bon
indirectement ça n'a pas été le cas et
avec 1,5 ou 2 pour
des lecteurs en plus c'était insuffisant
pour que ça change la donne notre
objectif c'est d'exister la majorité
présentielle n'a pas d'élu à ce jour
certains s'y était rapproché mais n'a
pas d'élu élu avec elle
évidemment au département ou région
aujourd'hui nous on a certain nombre de
centaines d'élus au conseil
départementaux je parle en francs 100 au
total est aussi dans les conseils
régionaux donc ça permettra de porter
une voix différente qui sont là daily
mail à 19 parlementaires en bourgogne
franche-comté 1 points sur 45 dans royal
à elle a des élus d'importance mais je
pense que les françaises et des
bouillants franc comtois comme les tous
les français sont capables de faire la
part des choses pour les gens debout que
je prends l'exemple de brigitte
bourguignon qui a été très bien réélu
sur législative partielle
c'est pas pour ça qu'on marche a gagné
là où elle a été élue donc les gens sont
capables de faire la différence entre
les scrutins
je vous propose tout de suite qu'on
retrouve en duplex julien odoul en
duplex depuis deux ans sombre soir
julian double merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes donc la tête de liste du
rassemblement national vous avez réalisé
9 4% des suffrages c'est neuf points de
moins qu'en 2015 c'est dur à encaisser
sage ni en double excusez moi je vous
vous êtes trompés dans ce jeu par votre
décompte
oui pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi
effectivement je vous ai donné le score
de judicature you would steinitz vous
avez obtenu 23 7% des suffrages c'est
donc bien moins qu'en 2015
est ce que est ce que ce soir c'est une
défaite pour vous alors déjà on va
attendre le décompte total de tous les
bulletins
ensuite oui vous avez raison c'est une
formidable défaite
c'est une extraordinaire des routes pour
la démocratie pour notre système
démocratique
aujourd'hui quand on voit ces chiffres
extrêmement inquiétant de l'abstention
partout en france quand on voit cette
telle désaffection démocratique
oui c'est une défaite évidemment et je
pense que chacun
toutes les listes les candidats sortants
qui ont été reconduits partout en france
et l'abstention évidemment à ultra
favoriser les sortants doivent traiter
ces résultats avec beaucoup d'humilité
beaucoup de calme beaucoup
était car je le dis avec avec avec
beaucoup de gravité ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui est extrêmement grave pour
notre démocratie que autant de
citoyennes et de citoyens finalement se
considère comme en marge de notre
système démocratique considère que ça ne
fonctionne plus considère que ça ne va
pas améliorer leur quotidien et donc
malheureusement peuvent trouver d'autres
moyens de s'exprimer tout ça est
extrêmement préoccupant néanmoins dire
au général
je voulais excusez-moi dayan juin votre
score est en net recul par rapport aux
régionales de 2015 vous parlez de
l'abstention effectuant les sept
abstentions elles vous touchent d'abord
vous rassemblement national
est ce que vous payez une sorte de bien
normalisation peut-être est-ce que je
l'incarné plus la colère pourquoi nous
payons pourquoi nous payons d'ailleurs
nous ne sommes pas là pour incarner la
colère nous sommes là pour incarner des
idées et pour incarner une autre vision
de la politique cela pour incarner la
colère mais ensuite effectivement nous
sommes
les principales victimes de cette
abstention puisque les catégories
populaires et les jeunes ne sont pas
mobilisés ont considéré que ces
élections étaient soit accessoires
soient ces élections n'étaient pas
comprises illisible soit n'ont pas été
informés et je revient évidemment sur ce
désastre de la distribution des
professions de foi où bon nombre de nos
concitoyens en bourgogne franche comté
et notamment dans les territoires les
plus ruraux n'ont rien reçu à la fois
pour les élections départementales et
régionales
et force est de constater que
aujourd'hui en 2021
malgré le numérique malgré les chaînes
d'info malgré la politisation des débats
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne
s'aperçoive qu'il ya une élection
seulement et uniquement quand ils
reçoivent l'enveloppent avec les
professions de foi et les bulletins un
mot j'aimerais dire s'il vous plaît un
mot donc pour marie-guite dufay que je
tiens déjà à féliciter de manière
républicaine pour ça pour sa victoire
je tiens aussi à lui dire d'être
extrêmement prudente prudente mesuré car
la majorité qu'elle détient aujourd'hui
au conseil régional n'est pas la
majorité populaire la majorité qu'elle
détient au conseil régional tirer des
urnes de ce soir est issu de la minorité
populaire voilà donc il faut dans les
politiques qui vont être menées dans les
choix et dans la façon de faire de la
politique il faudra entendre ce message
de l'abstention car encore une fois une
très large majorité de nos concitoyens
ne sont pas exprimés et donc et donc
n'ont pas validé le projet de madame du
fait ça il faudra l'entendre et surtout
de la part des sortants qui ont été
reconduits ce soir julien houle vous
vous restez avec nous on a encore deux
trois questions à vous poser on va faire
réagir jérôme durain marie-guite dufay
n'a pas la majorité c'est ce qu'on vient
d'entendre qu'est ce que vous avez à
répondre à juniors ont fait peut-être
pas tellement envie mais visiblement on
fait quand même plus envie que julien
odoul parce que s'ils ont sacré compris
si on n'a pas la majorité il l'a moi
donc je crois qu'il fait tout le monde
est modeste et et les deux fait quand
même qu'on doit retenir c'est
effectivement 7 abstentions dont on ne
peut pas satisfaire et qui pose des
questions démocratique majeur et c'est
aussi cette catastrophe de la
distribution de la propagande officielle
qui c'est un naufrage
c'était un naufrage au premier tour
c'est une catastrophe au second
on peut pas considérer qu'on peut avoir
des élections avec une organisation
aussi déficiente et là des questions de
est repoussé au gouvernement pour
comprendre comment pour arriver à ce
niveau de catastrophe
julien odoul vous n'avez pas réussi à
faire un très bon score aussi à sens
dans l'yonne votre ville vous êtes
derrière marie-guite dufay la cense vous
êtes derrière gilles platret est ce que
vous payez pas aussi vous vos
embrouilles y'en a un terme aux conflits
en interne souvient tous pendant votre
campagne que des gens votent listes
seront appelés à voter pour d'autres
listes et certains ont même refusé
d'apparaître sur des affiches non mais
pas du tout vous savez les cibles de
l'abstention ils le sont au niveau
national il n'y a pas de microclimat en
bourgogne franche comté et d'ailleurs
regarder au niveau du département de
l'yonne où je suis implantée depuis
plusieurs années leur assemblée
nationale réalise de très bons scores
donc il n'y a évidemment aucun lien avec
cette la campagne de boules puantes ou
autres le résultat on le voit partout en
france et que nos électeurs ne sont pas
venues aux urnes
voilà c'est une réalité il y avait plus
de 70% au premier tour des électeurs du
fn qui ne s'étaient pas déplacés là je
ne sais pas pour le second ce qu'il en
est mais la réalité c'est qu'ils ne se
sont pas déplacés pour tout un tas de
raisons qu'on a pu évoquer pour une
raison aussi essentiel qui à mon avis
devrait éviter de tirer des leçons sur
la place du rassemblement national sur
l'échiquier politique
beaucoup de nos électeurs beaucoup de
nos concitoyens considèrent que tout
changera avec l'élection présidentielle
il considère que les élections
intermédiaires finalement son nom est
essentielle et n'apportent pas grande
utilité
c'est un tort je le regrette mais en
tout cas moi je n'ai entendu énormément
et beaucoup nos électeurs seront
présents l'an prochain pour faire gagner
marine le pen c'est ça la réalité
vous êtes vraiment sûr de sa geôle où le
parti le parti est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi une remise en jeu dans les ventres
ligne parce que je vais être plus
vraiment contre l'euro venait le sjo
vraiment pour la sortie de l'union
européenne les gens sont peut-être perdu
vous et vous avez fini par perdre vos
électeurs non
monsieur chevreuil la dernière élection
nationale qu'est lieu dans notre pays
c'est des élections européennes leur
assemblée nationale les a gagnés en 2015
je tiens à vous rappeler que le parti
ait l'air avait gagné un stand de région
et semblait regonflé deux ans après il
n'était même pas au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle marine le pen
guettait donc la réalité c'est que les
nos concitoyens font évidemment la
différence entre l'élection
présidentielle la place de marine le pen
et duras ou nationales au niveau
national et des élections locales et
intermédiaires on l'a vu et d'ailleurs
comme aux élections municipales ce sont
les sortants qui ont été reconduits
l'abstention a favorisé les sortants à
favoriser les exécutifs qui était en
place
d'ailleurs qui sont très mal élu par
rapport à 2015 chaque évidemment chaque
sortant perd des voix perd des suffrages
depuis 2015 c'est le seul enseignement
que l'on peut tirer il ya aucune
évidemment aucun enseignement à tirer au
niveau national et on le verra bien ces
prochains mois avec la campagne
présidentielle merci beaucoup julien en
double en direct de besançon merci à
vous je vous propose d'écouter une
réaction messieurs avant de continuer
celle de gilles platret le candidat ait
l'air c'était il ya quelques minutes on
écoute je le paie très c'était pour nous
un moment important que cette campagne
un moment qui j'allais dire marc un plat
dans la volonté qui est la nôtre de
donner du sens à ses idées politiques
que nous pouvons et ne pourront jamais
réduire à la gauche d'un côté alliés
aujourd'hui à l'extrême gauche et à une
extrême droite qui est déplorable et qui
doit absolument être combattu parce
qu'elles entraîneraient infailliblement
le pays à sa ruine si elle devait demain
gagner donc c'est pour nous un enjeu
très très fort et nous avons défendu ses
convictions
vous avez été plus nombreux à choisir de
porter votre suffrage sur nous et c'est
un encouragement que cette progression
entre les deux tours
rien n'était joué bien sûr nous avions
parié sur le fait d'augmenter notre
participation
mais en tout cas on a réussi grâce à
vous à le faire sans doute pas à la
hauteur de nos espérances mais en tout
cas nous l'avons fait et c'est là aussi
porteur d'avenir je remercie les 116 que
lee
et qui sur la liste pour la bourgogne
pour la franche comté ont tout donné
dans cette campagne
ils ont donné une meilleur d'eux mêmes
ils ont mis un dynamisme extraordinaire
à faire valoir ses idées
il ya là des équipes qui se sont créés
et qui ne sont pas appelés à se
dissoudre de sitôt bien sûr tout le
monde ne pourra pas siéger dans ce qui
sera les rangs de l'opposition demain et
pour autant nous garderons le contact
parce que ce que nous avons fait
ensemble
là aussi est fondateur et nous devrons
le faire vivre dans l'avenir et on ira
plus loin dans quelques minutes puisque
gilles platret de vin devrait nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau dans quelques
minutes tout de suite en un point sur
les départementales avec catherine est
mesurée à gabrielle talon
oui tout à fait merci et elsa concernant
les départementales je vous propose
d'aller dans l'yonne où nous attend
patrick gendraud le président est claire
de ce département
mais exactement patrick gendraud dont on
va regarder tout de suite le résultat
puisque dans son canton de chablis il
est réélu avec plus de 73% des voiles si
on fait le bilan pour l'instant de ce
que l'on sait catherine dans l'yonne ça
fait actuellement donc dix cantons qui
sont pour la droite et un seul pour la
gauche mais un que lagos a chipé à la
droite
donc on va retrouver patrick gendraud
patrick gendraud votre réaction
est ce que vous pensez avoir une
majorité aussi confortable que pour les
six années qui viennent par rapport à
celles qui viennent de s'écouler bien
écoutez je voudrais tout d'abord salué
le résultat que sylvie champignons et
moi même avons fait dans le canton de
chablis et remercier toutes celles et
ceux qui nous ont accordé à nouveau leur
confiance
et puis je n'ai pas tous les résultats
naturellement sur l'ensemble du
département mais effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit nous avons un peu plus
de dix cantons qui reviennent à la
majorité sortante que j'avais l'honneur
d'entraîner et donc
pour vous répondre de façon précise je
ne peux le faire encore notre temps dans
la mesure où je n'ai pas tous les
résultats mais je pense que nous aurons
encore une majorité suffisamment
confortable pour continuer le travail
qui a été entrepris maintenant depuis
six ans et nous souhaitons continuer
pour le service de nos concitoyens il
connaît icaunaise voilà merci beaucoup
patrick gendraud avoue catherine alors
nous allons maintenant à lons le saunier
ville préfecture du jura où nous attend
thomas barthelet thomas bach tenez c'est
le candidat de gauche qui l'emportent ce
soit face à un binôme ou de droite donc
touba barthelet associé à christelle
plate et 52 2% des suffrages
il bat donc christophe bois qui était
conseiller départemental sortant qui
était donc un ancien adjoint de jacques
pélissard le maire divers droite de lons
le saunier monsieur barthelet vous avez
donc remporté ce canton et dans le même
temps de le 2 qui était le canton
historique de la gauche a basculé à
droite
donc c'est un peu un vous gagnez 1 vous
perdez mais déjà vous quelle est votre
réaction
en tant que premier adjoint de monsieur
ravier le maire de lons le saunier
bonsoir bas on est très heureux c'est
une vraie victoire quand même sur un
canton qui était tenu par là par la
droite
tout était tenue par la droite avec la
prime aux sortants dont on entend parler
partout dans tous les autres cantons le
gagner de manière assez large
sens 1 plus de 150 voix d' avance donc
pour nous c'est une vraie victoire
parfaite et complète très bien je vous
remercie beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur barthelet donc
je rappelle qu'en revanche le canton de
dole deux qui étaient détenues par la
gauche et notamment qui était un canton
historiquement au parti communiste a
basculé de gauche à droite françoise
barthoulot et philippe ginestet c'était
le dernier binôme de gauche au
département du jura
maintenant donc il y aura également
thomas barthelet et sa binôme je vous
propose maintenant d'aller entendre
georges hüe bialy georges duby ali donc
c'est l'un des candidats de l'union de
la gauche qui se trouvait en lice dans
l'un des cantons de besançon on va voir
tout de suite donc son résultat 51,1 %
et il met son binôme avec jeanne henry
bat le binôme de droite doc odile faivre
petitjean modem et à la halle aux
rigueurs des républicains george hill
bialy une vous vous êtes donc un membre
de l'union de la gauche vous êtes à
titre personnel adhérents si je ne me
trompe pas à ensemble donc le parti de
clémentine autain c'est rarissime qui
lie à un candidat de la gauche de la
gauche qui l'emportent à besançon notre
réaction
écoutez ça peut arriver la preuve ce qui
est important c'est que cette
candidature s'effectue s'est effectuée
dans le cadre d'une unité de la gauche
des différentes composantes de la gauche
et des écologistes et le résultat il est
celui à ce soir dans ces cantons nous
avons gagné nous avons battu la vice
présidente c'est quand même pas tout à
fait
n'importe quoi et j'ajoute et j'ajoute
que nous sommes un des rares ou si ce
n'est le seul canton que nous emportons
face à la droite dans le dans le
département du doubs donc grande
satisfaction évidemment oui vous dites
grande satisfaction mais en même temps
donc l'objectif c'était de bousculer un
peu christine bouquin donc la présidente
et l'air du département du doubs vous
n'y est pas arrivé non on n'a pas réussi
à l'unité à payer en partie pas
totalement
maintenant on a six ans pour manifester
les propositions et l'existence d'une
d'une position ferme et constructive
dans le futur conseil départemental
on verra bien comment les choses vont se
passer mais en tous les cas nos
propositions pour plus de social plus
d'écologie plus de solidarité on va
continuer à se battre et à faire des
propositions en tant qu il eut cette
fois ci non plus en tant que candidat
merci beaucoup monsieur ubbiali donc je
vous je rappelle que vous êtes donc élu
a besoin son conseiller départemental
je vous propose maintenant d'aller à
belfort plus exactement dans le canton
de belfort 3 ou se présenter yanbu car
le député et l'air du territoire voici
un reportage d'aline games qui est de
filets par b regardons jusqu'à la
dernière minute les électeurs sont venus
voter dans ce bureau de la maison de
quartier des forges le plus important du
canton avec 1122 inscrit non le bureau
de vote est clos
face à face tient debout car députés est
leur candidat et président de bureau et
annie morel greenblatt divers-gauche
ancienne conseillère municipale et
communautaire assesseuses du même bureau
les deux candidats se retrouvent donc
ensemble au dépouillement
on est content que la campagne se
termine que l'élection se terminent tous
impatients d'avoir
résultat il ya du stress un peu avant la
fin de campagne dans quelques minutes
à savoir ce que ça donne beaucoup et la
distraction 482 autant dans ce fief du
modem christophe grudler député avait
laissé sa place à jean christophe messin
éliminé dès le premier tour
une heure pour ouvrir toutes les
enveloppes et finalement dans ce bureau
yanbu car l'emportent avec 35 voix de
plus cani morel greenblatt on peut dire
que les filets ont tremblé mais on n'a
pas marqué on n'a pas marqué leur n'a
pas marqué le but je pense que une fois
de plus les électeurs ont été trompés
par le dernier tract qui a été distribué
dans les boîtes aux lettres qui nous
assimiler avec des candidats d'extrême
gauche avaient un appel à voter pour la
liste de gauche de la part de du député
européen l'eau de l'air et dans le
bureau de vote il a été le plus fort
sans faute historique on est assez
nettement en tête
ce qui ne nous arrive pas si souvent ici
on parle donc satisfait ben oui on est
très satisfaits des résultats ici au
fort je vous confirme score serré et une
participation bien supérieur à la
moyenne
plus de 43 % des inscrits sont venus
aujourd'hui mettre leur bulletin dans
l'urne google je vous propose de
repartir sur le plateau des régionales
ont peut-être marie-guite dufay devrait
faire une déclaration
avouez-le za merci ben justement
catherine que vous avez raison on va
tout de suite retrouvé en duplex
marie-guite dufay merci d'être avec nous
marie-guite dufay ce soir c'est quoi
c'est la victoire de c'est votre
victoire c'est la victoire de la gauche
n'aurait de voir que ce rassemblement de
la gauche que je que j'ai voulu j'aurais
voulu dès le premier tour et qui s'est
réalisé au second tour est bien a donné
lieu à une très très belle dynamique qui
fait que je rassemble même au delà de la
gauche donc je remercie vraiment très
très chaleureusement tous ceux toutes
celles qui m'ont fait qu'ils m'ont fait
confiance
bien sûr je reçois toujours cette gifle
que nous avons reçus la semaine dernière
elle est toujours la même
cette gifle de l'abstention parce que là
c'est vraiment un gros gros sujets de
préoccupations démocratiques mais pour
tous ceux qui se sont exprimés
merci cette victoire m'honore cette
victoire nous oblige nous oblige à un
travail très ambitieuse jeu je peux
penser que ce résultat c'est le résultat
aussi d'un travail très très conséquents
depuis cinq ans que bien sûr je vais
avoir à coeur de continuer
marie-guite dufay à droite où on annonce
que vous serez otages à la fois des
communistes et des écologistes que
répondez vous écoutez je vois pas
pourquoi je serais otages
c'est une drôle de conception des
alliances quand dans le mandat 2010 2015
j'étais allié avec les écologistes
je n'étais otage de rien et nous avons
construit des politiques qui dure
toujours
donc moi ce que j'ai cherché à faire
c'est pas du tout à me ligoter ni à me
rendre prisonnière de quoi que ce soit
la preuve c'est que le programme que
j'ai eue pour le premier tour c'est
quasiment le même pour le second tour
avec quelques ajouts quelques
compléments tenant aussi bien aux
volontés des communistes que volonté des
écologistes mais nous n'avons pas
modifié fondamentalement nous on garde
nos engagements vous avez entièrement on
se ressemble et par la violence est
aujourd'hui pour une région c'est une
très belle alliance pour une région plus
forte en matière de solidarité on en a
besoin de ces solidarités est plus forte
en matière de transition écologique
parce que la question de l'écologie est
une priorité absolue
oui j'ai confiance et il c'est le point
de départ la confiance parce que sans
confiance on ne construit pas grand
chose marie-guite dufay on a parlé
depuis le début de la soirée de cette
abstention entre 62 9 % d'abstention de
notre région est ce que vous vous dites
vous je suis mal élu ce soir
non non je ne me dis pas ça parce que je
pense à tous ceux qui se sont déplacés
puis qui sont venus s'exprimer
donc ce n'est pas ce qui ne s'exprime
pas qu'ils doivent l'emporter mais mais
il faut absolument travailler cette
abstention qui n'est pas dû à notre
région qui est un phénomène national
donc ça c'est vraiment un gros un gros
sujet de préoccupation pour lequel il
nous faut travailler et apporter des des
solutions qui sont à la fois locales un
régional sur la façon de travailler
notamment peut-être avec les jeunes des
le lycéen sur la culture de
l'instruction civique de la connaissance
de nos institutions
et puis sur la façon d'associer les
jeunes lycéens étudiants jeunes actifs
jeunes demandeurs d'emploi à nos
politiques
donc ça on va y travailler mais je pense
que si au niveau national il y à des
mesures aussi à mettre en place autour
peut-être d'un vote plus facile pour les
jeunes mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
trouver les mécanismes de contrôle par
rapport à un vote par exemple un vote
numérique
marie-guite dufay vous êtes aujourd'hui
septuagénaire s'était pas injure de le
rappeler est ce que première question
gouffre et l'intégralité du mandat à la
présidence et deuxième question est ce
que votre rôle aussi désormais ce n'est
pas de préparer la suite de préparer une
nouvelle génération notamment parti
socialiste je ne suis pas sûr monsieur
chevreuil que vous auriez posé la même
question
un homme suit j'aurais posé la même
question par exemple quand angers
il est bien évident que il me faut c'est
une responsabilité
il me faut absolument faire en sorte que
des jeunes prennent le maximum de
responsabilités
c'était déjà le cas dans le mandat
précédent
on va continuer bien entendu marie-guite
dufay une dernière question et au rayon
vous libère comment vous allez fêter
cette victoire ce soir on je vais
retrouver tout simplement mes colistiers
je vais retrouver une bonne partie ici à
dijon
et puis je pense que dans la semaine je
vais avoir l'occasion d'en retrouver
aussi notamment à besançon puisque j'ai
dû quitter besançon pour pouvoir être
ici à dijon à la préfecture de région
qui centralisait les résultats et donc
dès demain ou après demain je serai
aussi avec deux ans sans bien entendu
merci beaucoup marie-guite dufay en
direct de la préfecture de région
merci marie-guite dufay donc dont on
rappelle que sa liste a obtenu 42 5% des
suffrages estimation ipsos steria gilles
platret nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
tête de liste les républicains 24 4% des
suffrages vous terminer deuxième de ce
second tour déjà votre première réaction
vous êtes déçu c'est pas de la déception
on est on n'est jamais heureux de ne pas
gagner une élection être très clair je
peux avoir affronté que ce soir on saute
de joie parce qu'on finit deuxième
mais je pense qu'on a ouvert un certain
nombre de chemins j'ai regardé un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé dans les autres
régions où la gauche conserve vous avez
vous savez comme moi que toutes les
régions restent finalement là où elle
était les sortants sont réélus enfin
rouler sur policier france et dans les
régions où la droite était le challenger
comme la nôtre finalement nous faisons
le meilleur score est de loin ça veut
dire quelque chose ça veut dire que le
rassemblement qu'on a constitué dès le
premier tour qui a fait beaucoup causer
comme vous le savez avec debout la
france avec le mouvement écologiste
indépendant a sans doute permis que nous
résistions mieux qu'ailleurs et que nous
avancions davantage qu'ailleurs
après encore une fois je suis très
respectueux du scrutin je vous entends
des d'ailleurs demandé tout à l'heure si
finalement la faible participation
pouvait enlever une once de légitimité
normale à mme dufay a gagné cette
élection
on va quand même pas donner une prime à
ceux qui se déplacent pas pour voter
elle est élu et légitime gelé d'ailleurs
félicité dès 20h je lui ai dit néanmoins
pour que les choses soient très claires
je vous le dis à vous ce soir que nous
devons quand même nous interroger sur ce
qui s'est passé
encore aujourd'hui les témoignages ont
afflué de la non distribution des
professions de foi
dans la forêt de chevigny saint sauveur
on a retrouvé des caisses entières qui
était posée au milieu des bois avec les
professions de foi qui n'ont jamais été
acheminés donc j'ai bien madame du fait
parce que je voulais la prévenir avant
toute chose que nous avions déposé un
recours non pas contre sa victoire elle
est acquise mais contre le gouvernement
qui a foiré foiré cette élection comment
nous france c'est seulement de la faute
du gouvernement la bst en attendait mais
je vous parle pas de ça je vous dis
simplement que on a un problème
démocratique
vous avez des électeurs qui n'ont pas eu
la documentation pour faire leur choix
je encore une fois je ne vois pas
comment est le cas pour tous les
candidats
c'est carré jeu mais sans vouloir encore
une fois porté atteinte à la victoire de
madame du fait on sait très bien que
moins vous avez d'informations sur les
challengers plus vous accorder une prime
aux sortants et ça joue d'ailleurs dans
les régions qui sont gouvernées par la
droite
de la même façon donc en tout cas c'est
une erreur monumentale et le ministre
d'intérieur que j'avais interpellé et
que les sénateurs bailleur avait
interpellé la semaine dernière devra
rendre des comptes
d ils arrivent saboter cette élection le
gouvernement a foiré comme le dit j'ai
peut-être ma connaissance gérald
darmanin elle n'est pas facteur et tous
et par l'absence de réponse denis
thuriau si je peux finir monsieur
platret c'est vrai pas là couvrables à
vous savez je suis le fidelity parce que
j'ai même pas reçu la propagande des
régionales alors je me suis rappelé pour
qui voter non plus voilà alors sur 5 sur
le plat s'est rappelée pour qu'un à
voter maintenant je vais vous le dire
moi c'est pas le premier scrutin sous
d'autres gouvernements g par dessus la
propagande électorale par contre ça a
été fait face ont démultiplié et a
regretté
en venant sur plateau gt que prémices au
téléphone il me disait qu'il ya des
départements où la distribution plutôt
bien marché ça n'a pas fait baisser le
taux d'abstention c'est à voir je sais
que monsieur flo faire court très bien
ces temps d un etat de droit que ceux
qui souhaitent faire des recours face et
je pourrai quelque part en faire un
parce que je pense aussi que j'ai loupé
des voix comme mes concurrents de la
même façon et c'est à regretter alors on
peut toujours s'acharner contre le
gouvernement quand on est maire je plais
trail c'est bien l'écheveau responsable
de tout casser au niveau des nationales
ces gouvernements surtout au niveau des
prestataires coop a fait le job et je
crois savoir que les choses risquent
d'être prise en régie et c'est tant
mieux parce que je pense
qu'effectivement c'est bien que l'état
assume cela mais on en est tous des vies
après voilà ce dont on parlait dans la
première partie cette soirée est ce que
d'accord il ya ce problème de
distribution mais ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi un roger tout simplement de la
classe politique est ce que vous ne
devez pas tous les uns les autres
prendre votre part ce pas que ce soit un
rejet de la classe politique parce que
regarder il ya une grande adhésion des
francis latif parti avec plus de 2 de
votants non bien sûr que non je pense
qu'il ya une vraie vitalité de la
politique territoriale à inventer je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne se
reconnaissent plus dans ce cas un
conseil départemental ce qu'un conseil
régional et s'ils sont deux
collectivités qui sont très utiles
il y avait une tentative du gouvernement
hollande de de revoir cela entre un
partage davantage entre les les
intercommunalités les régions ça n'a pas
été au bout je pense qu'il faut vraiment
qu'ils aient une prise en main et
redonner un sens à ce que sont ces
collectivités qui son quotidien au
service des français mais qui ne le
perçoivent pas les inadéquations jérôme
durand il ya quand même un épuisement
démocratique et une fatigue démocratique
c'est évident et d'ailleurs comme l'a
dit gilles platret justement ça n'enlève
rien au mérite de ceux qui se sont
déplacés
les électeurs qui vont remercier et on
voit qu'ils ont exprimée en revanche il
ya un sujet de l'adhésion au système
palais gilet jaune c'est pas si vieux
que ça donc il ya des gens qui contourne
la voie démocratique pour exprimer leurs
envies leurs besoins leur colère
autrement et ce qui est inquiétant d'une
certaine r c'est que même le
rassemblement national qui était enfin
c'est une très bonne nouvelle et merci à
gilles platret de l'avoir relégué en
troisième position au passage mais même
ce parti qui est anti système perd ce ce
monopole là pour les élections
régionales et départementales élections
régionales départementales qui sont les
scrutins les plus arides
parce que les moins facilement compris
le maire reconnaît vous êtes bien passé
messieurs pour le savoir président lui
qu'on le connaît législatives c'est
juste derrière ces deux élections c'est
compliqué donc on attendait un travail
de fond à faire que les jeunes ne se
déplace pas est embêtant est une vraie
préoccupation que
les classes populaires ne se déplace pas
est une vraie aux préoccupations on a
beaucoup ri dans le mandat notamment la
droite dans le mandat écoulé de
démocratie participative de nos cafés
citoyens nous avons cherché avec
marie-guite dufay à renouveler ce lien
c'est difficile et on voit bien que
quand on n'est pas entre deux élections
à aller chercher les gens les associés
s'est compliquée la convention citoyenne
lancée par monsieur macro ça se termine
quand même par une gifle parce que
finalement je prendrais tout sans filtre
et je ne reprend rien c'est embêtant
donc il faut qu'on trouve des moyens
pour associer les gens à la démocratie
ses nobles de s'engager
moi je fais ici tous les candidats c'est
nord de s'engager c'est respectable
d'aller voter
la démocratie ça n'est pas inutile il
faut qu'on en convaincre les électeurs
que serait bien dire le sénateur du rhin
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
juste qu'on se dise qu'on n'a pas de
système alternatif au système
démocratique et que si une partie de
notre population a le sentiment qu'elle
est mal représentée elle a une liberté
extraordinaire c'est de se présenter
elle-même faut jamais oublier ça donc
dire c'est la faute des élus ont aux
caisses et vous savez là pour le coup
c'est pas une nouveauté de notre époque
contemporaine
regardez donc l'histoire de france 2
marine personne qui a une france qui ce
qui se détourner du cices l'âge de la
politique des médias
je sais juste comme historien de le
mettre en perspective on a eu des
périodes c'était encore beaucoup plus
tendue qu'aujourd'hui et des crises y
compris dans la troisième république
naissante a les bons reparler de la
crise du boulangisme à une époque assez
peut-être très lointain c'est quand même
des crises de la démocratie à m'ont
donné la démocratie était plus fort donc
on est dans une crise mais je le dis
bien ya pa ti scène alternative sinon la
dictature
donc quand on refuse de voter on laisse
les autres voter à sa place c'est un
choix qu'on prend mais il faut bien
qu'on dise que nous nous serons toujours
les citoyens quelles que soient les
étiquettes d'ailleurs et surtout ceux
qui s'engagent sur des listes les
gardiens de l'exercice de la
souveraineté à travers l'élection il n'y
a pas de système alternatif et je crains
parfois que certains profitent de ce
désordre pour faire avancer des tests
qui ne soient pas des tests de
démocratie s'abaisser c'est toujours
quand vous n'avez plus cool a regretté
jouissons de cette liberté qui nous est
donné donc il ya un vrai travail
d'éducation
je suis pas sûr je veux pas relancer des
barbies d'abord on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter que les cafés citoyens soit la
panacée
j'avais quelques idées
vous l'avez suivi aussi dans ma campagne
sur comment est-ce qu'on rapproche un
peu la région des habitants je
proposerai ses idées dans l'opposition
je pense que les maisons départementales
de la région serait sans doute une façon
mais on aura l'occasion d'en parler et
nous ferons notre travail d'opposant
pour proposer aussi des choses illégales
et à revenir sur lui aujourd'hui sur le
score de votre liste ce soir on le voit
avec les résultats des départementales
il ya six départements sur huit en
bourgogne franche comté qui vont rester
à droite ça veut dire que les électeurs
ont voté pour des binômes de droite
sortant la plupart du temps mais pour
marie-guite dufay en majorité pourquoi
vous n'avez pas réussi à capter cet
électorat qui va ta droite au
départemental côté je pense qu'on l'a
encore une fois j'essaye de replacer
cela dans un contexte plus large
il ya globalement partout en france une
prime à la reconduction de ce qui était
aux affaires
vous l'avez rappelé six départements de
droite vont rester à droite et les
départements les régions de droite dont
l'essai à droite et les régions de
gauche vont rester à gauche je sais pas
ce que ça donne sur le plan national sur
le département
mais j'imagine que la gauche va
consolider l est aussi ses positions
donc en fait je n'habite pas votre
question bien sûr que j'aurais aimé est
à 42 % ont ce soir rassembler plus
largement on a on a essayé nous et ça
fait écho à une interpellation vous avez
lancé un manet mme dufay tout à l'heure
on a essayé d'alerter notre électorat de
la droite et du centre sur les dangers
qu'il y avait cette constitution d'une
nouvelle majorité ps pc et surtout
europe ecologie les verts
moi je vais vous dire simplement ce
qu'il va se passer ça va être la foire
dans pagne toujours et si vous ne me
croyez pas regardez donc ce qui s'est
passé vendredi soir au conseil municipal
de besançon
puisque la mère que le gilet vert été
mise en minorité par le parti socialiste
y ont de sa majorité qui s'appelle le
parti socialiste et ça va être comme ça
l'air sur le projet de doublement de rn
57 pour les non mise en point qui nous
un regard assez intéressant mais ce que
je veux simplement vous dire c'est que
je pense aujourd'hui qui voit là il faut
respecter le résultat je le respecte
mais en tout état de cause nous serons
une opposition résolue pour éclairer les
électeurs demain je propose qu'on
poursuit la discussion dans quelques
minutes aura faire un bref et court
passage sur le plateau des
départementales cette avocate rennes oui
bref et coup j'ai bien compris le
message
vous avez la parole gabriel pour nous
résumer
situation pour les départementales en
bourgogne a alors en bourgogne
à l'heure actuelle on peut dire qu'il y
a deux départements où il n'y a
quasiment pas de suspense la
saône-et-loire et l'yonne deux
départements à majorité de droite qui
vont garder ses majorité voire pour le
cas de la saône et loire qui vont
l'accentuer en revanche dans les deux
autres départements dans la nièvre et la
côte d'or c'est plus serré et on voit
qu'on assiste à pas mal de bascule par
exemple en côte d'or est bien de bascule
de la gauche vers la droite et à savoir
les villes de talent et de se baigner et
puis j'en lis et dijon iv qui passe à
gauche dans la nièvre même situation
entre le parti socialiste et puis
l'alliance divers droite diverses entre
nevers 2 et saint pierre le moûtier
passe de gauche à droite et nevers 3 et
varennes vauzelles phase de droite à
gauche donc il reste encore du suspense
catherine pas de suspect n'a en revanche
pas de suspense en revanche en
franche-comté puisque il n'y aura aucune
aucun changement de majorité dans aucun
des quatre départements à savoir dans le
doubs la surprise c'est que georges du
bialé jeune henry qui sont tous les deux
de la gauche de la gauche gagne besançon
4 donc ce canton bascule de droite à
gauche
donc c'est l'union de la gauche qui
remporte ce canton bisontin dans le jura
2 bascule une dans un sens ou dans
l'autre à savoir que l'once 1 et ceo
thomas barthelet et sa binôme thomas
bartlett ans le premier adjoint à la
mairie de nom ce qui remporte ce canton
pour la gauche
en revanche la gauche perd le dernier
vraiment bastion de gauche à savoir
donne deux en haute saône dont cloud se
devait rester à gauche mais deux cantons
donc ont basculé de gauche à droite à
savoir villersexel et port sur saône
et puis dans le territoire de belfort 3
bascule ce qui fait travail ce culte
donc de gauche à droite de droite à
gauche et puis du modem vers l'est
républicain
ce qui fait que florian bouquet le
président ait l'air de ce département
augmente sa majorité dans canton et puis
pour terminer il n'ya à l'heure je vous
parle aucun pineau rassemblement
national élu en franche comté
ni même en bourgogne me souffle gabriel
à tout à l'heure
merci catherine à tout à l'heure jérôme
durain vous êtes le président du groupe
majoritaire sortant expliquez-nous
peut-être alors il ya des doutes un
parmi vos opposants mais comment va
s'organiser la majorité il y aura trois
groupes c'est ça oui ça doit être ça il
devrait y avoir un groupe écologiste un
groupe communiste et puis un groupe
socialiste et alliés est ce que vous
vous craignez d'être otage de minorité
de blocage au partenaire je vais
rassurer monsieur platret ça va bien se
passer
ça va bien se passer et monsieur platret
on avait vu la campagne d'entre deux
tours les clics mais revers les
extrémistes extrême gauche mais monsieur
curieux ses habits s'y sont essayés non
ça va bien se passer parce que on a un
projet c'est une dynamique de
rassemblement qui vient de loin la
présidente n'a pas découvert dimanche
dernier qu'on allait faire alliance ça
vient de loin
donc il y a évidemment une convergence
sur le projet on aura peut-être moins
mal nous avec nos alliés que gilles
platret que ses amis sur par exemple la
suite des choix qu'il a fait pendant la
campagne
donc vous pensez à de vous la france par
exemple est ce que d'une nature you va
voter certains projets de marie-guite
dufay
vous savez la liste que je représentais
les très diverses et très composite donc
mais nous avons des gens de gauche les
gens qui peuvent se rapprocher la
majorité d'autres mois ce qui nous va
nous apporter d'abord on va être une
force nouvelle je rappelle que la magie
des prix ancien avait pas d'élu
véritablement en tout cas élu avec elle
ni dans les départements dits dans les
régions donc c'est une première fait
quatre ans que ce mouvement existe donc
ça n'est pas facile dans des élections
peu de gens vont voter
nous serons constructif voilà nous avons
aussi comme gilles platret nous avons
fait des propositions qui me semblent
intéressantes et qui pour l'hôte pour le
coup ne me sens pas clivante plus de
présenter les élus régionaux qui
pourrait dire le contraire gilles
platret propose des maisons moi je
propose est davantage de servir des
antennes et maison france service des
permanences pense que là dessus
messieurs il me semble qu on devrait
pouvoir se retrouver tous les trois et
puis s'il ya des choses qui nous
conviennent pas dans le jura ne troll au
cid de mouvements qui aura sa place et
qui sera parfois dire non s'il estime
que ça n'est pas dans ce qu'ils
souhaitent porter moi vous savez le
principal état d'esprit qui m'anime
c'est le pragmatisme et le bon sens donc
je pense qu'on est capteurs capables
d'en faire
je pense qu'il faut vraiment que je sois
intelligent pour nos habitants jérôme
durain allant tout à l'heure marie-guite
dufay n'a pas forcément bien pris la
question mais je vais vouloir poser à
vous quand même est ce qu'il ya et c'est
bah oui est-ce que
le parti socialiste qui n'a plus que
trois parlementaires sur l'ensemble de
la bourgogne franche comté trois
parlementaires sur 45 doit se renouveler
aujourd'hui tout est ce que ça passe par
le conseil régional la question du
renouvellement pour les formations
politiques est l'épousé en permanence et
quand on a perdu un grand nombre de
parlementaires comme c'est notre cas
lors des dernières législatives
on est obligé de se renouveler et il
faut se renouveler à tous les étages
et quand on perd des cantons faut se
renouveler donc ça passera par le
conseil régional à l'évidence mais ça va
passer à tous les étages
et ce travail les élections de ce soir
nous y invite en bourgogne franche comté
en tout cas on a plutôt des atouts pour
le faire
est ce que vous serez président du gros
fou écoutez on les élections le décompte
des butins n'est même pas terminée donc
l'assemblée d'installation a lieu
vendredi avoir un petit peu de ton
travail ces deux semaines pour organiser
tout ça on va peut-être donner les
derniers sur le dernier char notre
estimation ipsos steria notre partenaire
ce soir pour france télévisions vous
allez voir les chiffres 40 2,5 pour cent
des suffrages pour marie-guite dufay la
présidente socialiste sortante à la tête
d'une liste d'union de la gauche pour ce
second tour ps prg pcf europe ecologie
les verts
elle emporte donc largement ce soir
devant gilles platret 24,4 julien odoul
23,7 et denis thuriau 9 4%
merci jérémy on se retrouve dans un
petit quart d'heure juste après le
décrochage nationale reste avec notre
site merci
[Musique]